report from the daily wire says daily
wire co-ceo Jeremy boring called out
YouTube in a Twitter threat on Sunday
revealing a series of violations leveled
against his company's shows that he cast
as a betrayal of the video platforms
stated commitment to open debate in just
the last 90 days boring said accounts
associated with the daily wire have
received 104 violations for hateful and
derogatory content mainly directed at
commentary about transgender issues
there have been more than 200 violations
in the past few months he added accounts
for Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro Candice Owens
Michael Knowles Andrew Clavin Brett
Cooper and Jordan Peterson have all
received violations boring said
penalties include Walsh being
demonetized last month as you know and
the latest is that Owens and Knowles are
being suspended for seven days after
receiving a second strike and Peterson
got his first strike that's three
strikes in 90 days and an account well
once you get three strikes the account
is deleted that's what that's what
happens
so apparently
Candace Owens and Michael knows are on
their second strike
all YouTube has to do is find uh find
some sort of uh pretense to give him a
third strike and they're banished from
the platform forever
um boring said quote everyone you know
everyone knew the truth then just like
everyone knows men are not women YouTube
only does more damage the longer keeps
his finger on the scale the daily wire
has taken a firm line against the
radical transgender craze especially
when it comes to minors being subjected
to irreversible chemical and even
surgical treatment so
um this is what's happening and it's
it's all about the trans issue
so it's like I said 100 violations
almost all of them have to do with the
Trans issue
um and they also are
violations of policies that
are not written anywhere
that have not been that were not told to
anyone ahead of time
so YouTube basically just decided a few
few weeks ago that um missed quote
unquote misgendering is now going to be
a violation of their terms of service
they never said that before
that was that was never said but they
decided it and now they're using that as
a pretense and they're also it's not
even like
okay we've changed our policy and this
would be bad enough
if YouTube said last month let's say for
example
um we've changed our policy and now
misgendering is against the law here on
YouTube you can't do that anymore if you
do that we're gonna kick you off
uh and if you do that from now on we're
going to kick you up that would be bad
enough
but they're not that's not even what
they're doing
they are effectively changing the rules
and then and then retroactively
imposing those rules
on content that was made before the rule
was changed
now they'll claim that they're not
changing the rules at all because they
never said that you could quote unquote
misgender
uh yes but it was never stipulated
and you know it's like thousands of
videos were posted on the platform every
month for years
with people using biologically correct
pronouns and they never said anything
about it they never they never violated
anyone for it
and then they decide that they're going
to start doing it so obviously the rule
did change
but the way that they protect themselves
and they protect themselves from
lawsuits and everything else is by
making the rules
intentionally vague intentionally opaque
you know with policies like well you
can't have hateful conduct you can't you
can't engage in harassment
what does harassment mean like how can I
harass somebody with a YouTube video
okay if I'm sitting here in a studio and
I make a YouTube video there's nobody
else around me and I posted to this
platform with millions of other videos
um how could I be harassing someone
buying a new car can be a stressful
experience for anyone especially if
you're a first-time buyer or if you have
no credit before you walk into a
dealership and spend the entire day with
the crowds the stress the potential to
not even find the right car you need to
check out car Zing carzing is completely
changing the way that you buy a car
online by partnering with Credit
Agencies leaders and over 25 000 dealers
Nationwide karzing provides you with
everything you need before stepping foot
into the dealership once you find the
right car it's your ideal budget all you
got to do is bring your saved deal
voucher with you to the dealership to
finalize your next ride it is so simple
even if you're not in the market for a
new car you just check out carzing
anyway karzing's online window shopping
experience goes beyond mirror images you
can dive deep into each vehicle's
specifications features and performance
capabilities zoom in on craftsmanship at
the interior Marvel at The Cutting Edge
technology and admire the meticulous
attention to detail that sets these
automobiles apart from the rest karzing
helps make your experience faster
cheaper and less stressful so visit
carzing.com
today and find the best deals near you
that's carzing.com Walsh
yeah I suppose I could think of some
ways that you might be guilty of
harassing somebody
uh
or or you might try to you might try to
encourage others to harass someone like
there are ways you could do that
is that what they mean
does it mean that you know if I go on
YouTube and I give out somebody's home
address and I say
okay everyone grab your pitchforks and
go to this person's house
well obviously you can't do that is that
what you mean well no they don't mean
that well they mean yeah you can't do
that
but now they decided that uh if you just
use the word him
in relation to a man who prefers to be
seen as a woman now that's harassment
didn't say that before they never
stipulated that before but they keep it
vague just for this exact reason
so the question is why are they doing
this now
I mean like I said they're they're for
years and years and years
thousands of videos posted to their
platform every month with people talking
speaking openly and honestly about the
the trans issue using biologically
correct pronouns all the rest of it and
that was the case for years it was never
an issue it was never a problem and now
they've decided that it is
and why is that well the answer is
obvious because we're winning
like we're having a major impact
so you can look at the legislation
that's changed you can look at um
cultural changes you can look at uh the
you know polls and and surveys and all
that and see the way that um public
opinion is Shifting in our Direction on
this issue and I mean all of that is a
is a good indication
that
we're having success but
you really don't need any of that
because the number one indication is
this
you've got these major platforms like
YouTube
who come back around and say oh you know
what uh you can't say any of that
anymore
so you're making these arguments and
you're saying these things that are very
compelling to lots of people and you're
getting through to people
and you're persuading them and so uh you
can't do that that's not going to be
allowed
that is the real crime we committed
that's that is the actual violation that
we have committed
um we have been persuasive and effective
whatever else they say whatever you know
whatever language they use and they're
in their obscure terms of service and
all the rest of it
the the real rule is is that simple
that if you disagree with them
if you disagree with their ideology that
is YouTube's ideology which is the same
as the left's ideology which is just
leftism if you disagree with it
and you disagree effectively and
persuasively
um then that's a violation
and you could be as ineffective as you
want
sure there's lots of other
that's why you know anytime a
conservative gets uh gets penalized by
YouTube they always look at other
conservatives that are on the platform
and they say what about them why aren't
you going after them
you know they're doing things they're
they're doing the same thing
um or the fact they might even be more
offensive by your standards
but no the reason they're targeting you
is because they have they have um
determined that you are a threat a
special threat
and that's why now they're going after
the entire daily wire
you know um platform if you'd like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed